it's harder having a dog because
children develop and dogs just stay
dumb and they never figure it out
and when you're i don't know if you've
ever had a dog that's had a medical
problem but you can't get their
cooperation
when you that you need to help them
because you can't say them you know you
have this problem you see
yeah i had this dog when i took my dog
to the vet the first time
uh she was a i don't know a year old
when i adopted her and the vet told me
don't let your dog eat dark chocolate i
don't know if you know this but i've
heard this that
yeah it's dark chocolate is supposed to
be poison to dogs kills them
and vets won't explain it further either
it's like why does it kill them oh
just they die like they won't tell you
what
like what do i do if my dog eats dark
chocolate watch her die or leave the
room
but the vet did tell me there's one
thing you can do
which is give your dog hydrogen peroxide
and that foams up
in the dog's belly and then they throw
it up with the chocolate that's what you
should
know to do that but you gotta do it
quickly before they ingest the chocolate
all right so i come home like uh six
months later sure enough my dog get dark
chocolate i had friends who had stayed
over and they didn't know they left dark
chocolate in low places
right which is very uh
here's a good place for this yes
i could put it on this high shelf but i
think not
they put it down i may be crawling on
the floor later that's right you might
not need a snack
so what so you're calling my dog had
your dog eating i'm eating a whole big
bar of dark
polish chocolate the polish part doesn't
matter but i like saying polish
chocolate
and my dog had chocolate on her face and
and i went oh my god
and she looked at me like i was home for
an hour alone what are you gonna you
know come on
and i was like you're gonna die and
she's looking at me like i don't
understand english but i get that you're
upset
and uh and so i'm thinking i gotta get
hydrogen peroxide into this dog but i
don't have any so i've got to go to the
pharmacy and she needs to come with me
because there's no time
i'm in new york city and i take my i put
the leash on her she's like excited
we're going for a walk
and i'm running and she's like this is
great for you you never exercise she's
just enjoying it
and then we get to the pharmacy and
she's waiting for me when i come out and
i've got a bottle of hydrogen peroxide
that i have to
make her drink yeah like take yourself
through that how do you
make a dog like you just hear drink this
you know so i kind of pour a little in
her snout and she goes
like that and so i kind of grab her and
i pour them once she
she goes i think i was pretty clear that
i didn't like that like she looks at me
like
she's trying to figure out what's going
on here and so i get my whole body
around her this dog was 70 pounds she
was like an alligator and if she didn't
want to drink something
she's just thrashing i'm like drink it
and at one point i have her on the end
of the leash and she's looking at me
all wet in the face and she gives me
this look like i don't know what
happened to you
but our thing is over you anymore
i'm a dog and she starts going all right
she became completely vicious
she's trying to bite me and i'm trying
to save her life yeah so i'm literally
i'm
punching her in the face and splashing
this stuff i'm holding her here
kicking her in the stomach
and people i look and there's hundreds
of people on the sidewalk just
horrifying yeah there's cars stopping
they're honking at me
she's gonna die i'm like this is a
nightmare and finally i got enough in
up her nose and whatever and she was
like
dude uh just huh
and then she just like a pump just and
just
brown yeah brown like she's like another
dog is coming out of her
and she made it but
she never liked me after that she hated
me because from her point of view i just
went
no you went nuts i lost my reason i'll
tell you this story about one time
that i thought i was gonna die i think
it's the only time where i thought
why wouldn't this be when i die i was on
a plane
i've been on a lot of planes and a lot
of shitty weather and stuff but this
[ __ ] was
[ __ ] up i was in indianapolis on a
plane
waiting to take off and we're sitting
there and the pilot comes on
and he says uh all right folks um the
fuel gauge is broken so we're waiting
for maintenance
so we wait about 20 minutes
and he comes back on folks the fuel
gauge is still broken
uh but we're gonna go anyway
uh we know how much fuel we have we feel
confident it'll be okay so we're gonna
go i'm thinking okay
well he's a pilot
i'm sure he's going by some manual that
says you know
if the fuel gauge breaks call
maintenance if they're not there in 20
minutes
[ __ ] it
fuel gauges are overrated just go you're
fine
just top it off and remember what
happened
so then we still don't take off and a
guy comes back on uh folks we have
another problem laguardia airport in new
york won't give us clearance to take off
because the weather has been bad there
intermittently so we're going to wait
for that
so we wait 20 minutes then he comes back
on folks laguardia still hasn't given us
clearance
but we're going to go anyway
we're looking at the radar we think the
weather will be fine
so what we're going to do is uh say that
our destination is philadelphia
we'll get clearance to go there halfway
to philadelphia we'll switch courses to
the gorilla airport we'll be heavier in
a few minutes
i swear to god he said this
first of all i'm pretty sure you're
supposed to be honest with the dude in
the tower
like does dude the tower have to go
really you're gonna come on
tell me where you're going
and why is he telling us this [ __ ]
am i gonna have to corroborate this lie
if we get pulled over by the sky police
at some point in the flight
oh no we're totally going to philly i
got a brother there and uh we got a
thing in philly
but i'm still fine with it because we're
travelers on the pla yeah
i got a thing [ __ ] it i'm immortal just
go please
yes go into marginal weather
with shoddy equipment secretly i totally
support his plan
so we take off we get
above where we are right now and it's
just a
black [ __ ] of a cloud it's just
like the wizard of
oz it's just there's trees thrown apples
at us it's crazy
it's just horrible and we're getting the
whole flight and we're making these
circles
and me and the guy next to me are both
listening to the tower you know how you
can plug into your seat sometimes
and you can listen to the tower talk to
the area airplanes
and we we keep hearing our guy trying to
get clearance to land
from laguardia ah this is delta 288 uh
requesting
clearance to land and it's a negative
288
low visibility a few minutes go by
as delta 28 we would really like
clearance to land
yeah that's a negative 288 like he was
getting annoyed
and meanwhile we're just circling
and burning this vague amount of fuel
we could just stop being an airplane at
any second
and then we hear this this is all true
this
the laguardia as laguardia airport to
all area airplanes we are closed for the
night
zero visibility not safe for landing
please divert to philadelphia or
allentown pennsylvania or boston
and then we hear our guys this is delta
we need we need to land now we have no
fuel we have no fuel we have to land
right now
interesting then there's a pause
and then we hear this
well then i'm clear to land
then 280 uh
that's how he said like dude
no one can see okay but just i
i guess all the dumb decisions you made
today have made this a good one
just take a shot i'm going home just
[ __ ]
turn the lights off after you crash i
don't give a [ __ ] frankly
by the way you're not supposed to be
here you [ __ ] liar you said you're
going to philly
so as soon as we get clearance we just
like we
start bulleting
we're either flying desperately towards
the ground or
falling i don't know that there's a
difference
we come out of the clouds and there's
the [ __ ] earth
right [ __ ] there it's right there
that's what low visibility means
we come out of the clouds no [ __ ] it's
right to jesus
and the plane just and you can feel the
plane go oh [ __ ] i can't do that
what are you nuts
and we go and veer over the highway i
swear to god i saw people in their cars
go what the [ __ ]
and we hit the runway like sideways
[Music]
and the pilot comes back on all true i
swear to god he's totally out of breath
he's like
welcome to our airport
new york city
you may turn on your cell phones now
and you may call your loved ones he said
that he said you may
call your loved ones and everybody on
the plane was
crying and rocking back and forth just
sobbing
calling their husbands and their wives
i'm divorced what am i gonna remember
you hate me well i almost died
i got in a cab and the cab driver goes
that was a very bad landing
i was like how'd you know that was me
it's like that's the only plane to land
in four hours
we all watched the drivers we said that
are going to die
1994 i went to russia and it had just
become russia
again it was the soviet union until
really that year
everything started to crash down and at
the time i was a writer
for the conan o'brien show and i had
written there for two years and i was
burnt out and i didn't want to do it
anymore
so i went to the head writer and i said
i have to quit because i think i'm going
to
have a nervous breakdown and he said
take two weeks off and we'll pay you for
the two weeks
and i said okay i'll do that
so i had nowhere to go and i thought
maybe i'll go to russia
i really don't know why i can't really
explain any decisions i made then
because i have children now so you don't
have to search when you have children
you're not like oh what what could i do
to enhance my life
you're just sort of compelled to do
whatever comes at you at a certain age
in life
but i was in my 20s i had no wife not i
had no
girlfriend even i just was this guy and
i had money from a
tv job and so i just said i'm gonna go
to russia because when i was a kid i
used to read russian novels
and i'd love them and i would open all
the windows so i would be cold and i
wanted to be cold like they were
so i just decided i'm gonna go and also
somebody told me that the wall had just
come down to the soviet union and that
russia was a really
crazy place at the time so i said i'm
gonna go there
i speak no russian i can't even look at
the alphabet
and understand what i'm looking at
there's no place more foreign to me than
russia
so i went i went to moscow
which is when you land in moscow it's
just forest
and there's a city in the middle of just
forest it's terrifying
and as the plane goes down you're like
no no no i didn't want to really do this
and the whole time there i couldn't fend
for myself
it was already a country that was just
broken in pieces
and the weirdest things happened to me
there and i just they just became normal
after a while
like i went i was in a restaurant and a
waiter came up to me not my waiter
and he said coca-cola and i said
uh-huh he said coca-cola
and i said sure i don't drink coca-cola
but i had learned by that point to just
don't
just go just do what they're asking you
to do sure
so he went to the kitchen and he got a
coke
and a can and he handed it to me and he
said five dollars
because only dollars were worth anything
there and i said okay
on my bill he said no five dollars me
now
so i gave him five dollars and he put on
his coat and he left
he just sold me a coke on the side
and then quit his job
so those are the kind of confusing
moments i was having there
and i couldn't talk to anybody and i was
so lonely it's
difficult i mean i was alone and i just
sit in the room go okay that was really
[ __ ] up day i hated that day
and i tried to watch television and the
tv was american shows like
dynasty and the way they translate they
didn't have
what they did was the sound is a little
down and there's just one man
saying all of the dialogue
over the whole show
i was there for two weeks and it just
was crushingly
i had made no contact with anyone
and then one day i went into the subway
now if you've never been to moscow
the one thing i learned there is that
well the streets are very i can't
gesture with this
it's beautiful but i can't keep punching
you in the face with a big white fist
okay the streets in moscow
during the cold war they were made wider
so that they could
have missiles going down the middle of
the street for the parades and if you go
there you'll find out if you go behind
the big buildings they actually tore the
buildings off of their foundations
and dragged them back and a lot of the
bigger buildings in moscow
in the back they're being held up by
like bricks it's really
unnerving how unsafe the whole city is
so the streets are very wide and you
can't cross the street on a green light
you'll never make it so they made
tunnels so you can go under and those
are connected to the subway
and the subway in moscow you go down in
an escalator and you keep going until
you think i
this is it just keeps going like this is
so
deep this is really upsetting
but anyway everyone hangs out in these
tunnels i went in the middle of december
i went to russia in the middle of
december
alone and i'm standing in the subway
and i'm watching a violin player and the
one thing about
russia still today i think is that no
one has any money
so when you see a guy playing the violin
in the subway he's like the first
chair violin for like the russian
symphony orchestra
because that doesn't pay [ __ ] and at
least he can get a few kopecks in the
subway
so i'm watching him and everybody these
other people are sitting on the floor
and we're crying everybody's crying
everybody it's just normal people are
just watching
just wiping away tears
and there's a young fella sitting here
and he looked my age i was 25 at the
time he looked about 25 and he was
tattered
and just watching this violin player
and then this group of kids walked by
about
eight children ranging from five to
ten years old and their faces were dirty
like you know like an oliver twist like
they were in a play
like they had rubbed dirt on their face
and they're all wearing men's coats
that they're wearing is like a dre like
you know from the neck down to the floor
and none of them have sleeves their
hands in their sleeves their sleeves are
just flopping
they were like street urchin kids
and the coats it just looked like these
men's coats
and you kind of knew all the men who
owned those coats are
dead and at least one of these kids
killed those guys like i
swear i looked at an eight-year-old's
face and thought he has murdered
and that's what they look like just
tough little kids and i could
i'd seen them before in moscow they work
in groups
the guy sitting below me that i
identified with
called out to the head kid in the front
i don't speak russian so i just knew he
was going uh
he's appealing to him but there's
he needed something and the kid with his
hands in his sleeve looked at him
suspiciously and said
this like what the [ __ ] why what do you
want from me
and the guy went explaining himself and
he showed that his
shoe had come apart and he showed
that his shoe was like a flap and he
showed the game but they did then he
showed him his shoe
and the kid shrugged and said this dude
like okay
and the kid's hand appeared from out of
the sleeve and there was a
a tube of shoe glue in his hand
he didn't rummage for it it was already
there
and he handed it to the guy and the guy
fixed his shoe with the glue gave it
back from juice dude
and then the kid from the other he took
another his other hand had a paper bag
and he put the glue in and he and he
huffed it
and his eyes rolled back and he got high
and then the group kept going and i
couldn't believe what i just saw
that the misery in this country at that
time
was so calculable and so
predictable that this guy thought my
shoe's broken
oh there's a child he's
sure to have some glue in his hand
because the state of our nation is so
wretched
and i looked and he looked at me and i
and i was
startled and then he laughed and i
laughed
and he's the only person i had any
contact with
in the whole of the soviet union and i
realized this is why i came here
to find out how bad life gets
and that when it's this bad it's still
[ __ ] funny
that's all i got thank you
i gotta also ask uh look at the boat
we'll have with your boat oh yeah yeah
that was that was all the sudden like
wow louie's like a tabloid guy
popping around his boat
just hanging out waiting for the [ __ ]
got stuck in the mud
uh his new black crow's album it was my
first test yes
i was my first day in the stuck in the
mud i just bought it
and i spent one day on it with some guy
who showed me the
specifics of the boat but it's a big
[ __ ] boat with two engines and it's
really complicated to drive
and i put my i took my girls out on it
and as we were pulling out of the marina
my daughter was like
how do you know how to do this and i was
like it's not that big a deal like i was
defensive with my
ten-year-old it's not that big deal i
could do this
and we went around manhattan and i got
in all this [ __ ] i had no
qualifications that's a crazy waterway
because it's the current
on these things especially what are they
what do they call that [ __ ] actuary
they call it devils something that's
like something
health health gate that's right yeah
right on the converge is right there
the rivers kind of split the long island
sound collides with the harlem right
right that's it it gets a little dicey
over there really
don't say the harlem river around
anthony today no i'm all right it's
sensitive there's been a renaissance up
there
in the moment when we were in that
cauldron and we just smashed like the
boat felt like it was coming apart and
my seven-year-old screamed and her
sister held her eyes
like close enough it was like i'm
putting
this is really stressful really yeah
just north of uh roosevelt island yeah
that's correct and are you thinking i
just want somebody who knows how to do
this here right now
and then we went up to the harlem river
which is very uh it's like a glass
yeah really nice and so now everybody we
got through it
and we're really happy and i i've got uh
frozen burritos and macaroni and cheese
so we're going to pull over
throw the anchor and we're going to make
lunch and uh
so i find this little cove this sweet
little cove
nice and uh in harlem there's yeah and
there's people
uh in a park next to it and it's just a
nice place where i pull in there
and the boat just stops moving all of a
sudden
and uh everything starts beeping
yeah the boat is cooled by water in that
it's sitting in
so now it's just sucking mud up into
this it's this
this two hour old engines
are now packed with mud
and i just shut everything off because i
know everything's overheated oh man
and my daughters go what's going what's
going on and i said i turned to them and
i said
you need not to ask me any questions for
a little while oh
[ __ ] yeah yeah and the park ranger calls
over to me from the shore
and he says you ain't going anywhere
it's low tide you're going to be stuck
there for a long time
and uh i'm like no no it's all right i
try not to let my daughters hear this
and i call i i call the coast guard
whatever that
channel 16 i'm like anybody can tow me
out of here and
yeah and these cops show up on the boat
uh and they're like 50 yards away and
they're not going to come anywhere near
me no
and they said yeah you're going to have
to wait till you're in high tide
yeah it's around one o'clock and i s and
i'm on the radio with the cops and they
go you're gonna have to wait to high
tide
and i said when's that and they said
maybe midnight oh no
my both my daughters start crying did
you stay the whole time or did you get
out
we could you can't there was no way to
get out because
we were surrounded by mud and it was
like quicksand
like i put a stick in it and it just
fell into the mud
were you embarrassed
[Laughter]
so you were pretty much just like no
more water your boat is sitting
in my mud in mud really and you're
waiting for the tide to come back
were you afraid i was just gonna be
stuck in the mud and i was
not gonna come up i was afraid my
daughter was like hot what if we like
heal over what if we start tipping over
them like that can't happen
and in my head i'm like that could
totally absolutely happen
and the cops said well they would go get
us food because we couldn't cook any of
the food now because it needs the
generator to grow it's like an
oven how would they get it to you well
that was a big
deal because they went they went and got
us food the cops they bought us a whole
chicken and some rice
really nice guys then they come back and
now there's a huge expanse of mud
between
us and that food and they go we don't
know how you're gonna get this
they put it in a garbage bag and i start
throwing a line to them
but it's not making it of course all
these people on the shore everybody
knows who i am
in the park and the shore who are just
on a rail just watching me
and i throw i'm throwing this like i've
tied a pot to the rope
and i throw it and it gets about halfway
there
and i'm pull it back and i'm covered in
mud because every time the rope comes
back it's
totally covered in mud and i have to get
the mud off so it's not heavy
every time i go to throw it all the
people on the side half of them are
going
well pull it for you louie you can do it
and then i when i miss they go
oh man that sucks
it's like playing left field for the
yankees totally the yankee stadium crowd
people food people wow
and i couldn't get it so finally the
cops pulled over a guy who was fishing
and they used his uh rod to throw me
away
and cast a weight over how nice i tied
it
they pulled and i had to pull dinner
onto the boat i was
so soaked in mud and sweat
totally then it was chicken mole after
that
kids had your kids calmed down by that
point they were great my kids were
amazing
and what happens at midnight we waited
and waited
once in a while like it started raining
a little bit and i heard some
from the darkness in the park some kid
go hey luis
ck it's raining out now
those guys at the marina where i keep
the boat they're really cool guys and
they sent
some kid some young guy uh and in a boat
and they just dropped him in the water
and he swam
to us jesus crazy kid and he came
on board with me and helped me get it
out once the water came up we
used the uh bow thruster to shove the
boat we got a little bow thruster yeah
were you feeling it rise as the water's
coming like oh god
the ball wasn't moving because the water
was coming up and the boat was just
sitting there in the mud so that's why
we used the bow thrusters are absolutely
loose wow we shook the boat around whoa
and it worked and at one point the tide
was starting to go down again and the
guy that was with me said
it's your call but we could put it in we
could turn the engines on and
put it in reverse and try to get it out
it won't work what'd you do yeah it was
like apollo 13 because everything had
been off for a long time and now we're
like he says we have 10 seconds of
battery
oh yes we fired up and just put it in
reverse and
mud just crazy
we don't have enough lamps to get louie
out of the mud
[Music]
you